most people do not have money issues
they have behavior issues that cause
money issues
so what are some of the biggest mistakes
that entrepreneurs make or some of the
things that they need to know that they
don't think about when they're starting
their business around money
i want to take the friction away from
all of your investing and i want to put
the friction
in for all of your spending i want to
make it harder for you to spend and
easier
for you to invest
mr mel abraham in the house what's going
on
i love oh look at the background you got
that you got the tv screens going with
the with the show
man it's been crazy so yeah we've got
we've got branding going on all over the
place
i love it what what are the chinese
things you got on the wall there you
know i lived in and trained in japan
i've been in the martial arts for 40
plus years these are my
hand-painted certificates from my say in
japan oh it's japanese
okay i see it okay that's awesome yeah
i didn't know that okay so guys if you
don't know mel abraham he's one of the
smartest
money people i know uh he is behind the
scenes to
a lot of the people that you know and
recognize
and i've been pushing this guy for a
while ever since i met him like mel
when's the show coming when's the
youtube channel coming people need to
know your name man
you gotta get all that goodness that's
in here and and one of the
one of the most heart centered people
you're ever going to meet too you got to
get into the world
and it's finally happening he launched
his new show
somebody says mel for president in the
house i love that
that's bo hawkins our mutual friend and
so he launched a new show
called the affluent entrepreneur
uh that you guys should go check out
tell me it's a youtube show too
yes it is all the episodes will be video
and audio and and uh
transcribes i mean you can digest it 12
ways from sunday
i i love it i'm excited dude we got it
we got to build this brand up okay so
there's a lot i want to ask you but why
don't we start with this like what
actually
you've been doing this for so long
you've helped so many people
what actually made the spark to say you
know what i'm gonna
i'm gonna turn this into a show like
what actually i know lots of people have
been pushing you and i was like a tiny
bit of that but
what actually got you to say now's the
time
uh literally it's been my last two years
journey so one of the challenges for me
was this
and this was i'm a cpa by education
and uh and i had i had a
dear dear friend of mine we were talking
because he's been pushing me also
um and james wedmore has been pushing me
also and he says why won't you go do
this
because i don't want to i said i i don't
want to get pushed back into that cpa
realm
you know hey mel can i buy an hour of
your time kind of realm because oh
he says to me he says here's the
challenge i see
he says you see yourself as a cpa
that happens to be a thought leader and
an entrepreneur he said
but what we all see you as is that
thought leader an entrepreneur that
happens to be a cpa
he says you have a process it works it
works for other people it works for you
it's time to get the process out there's
a need out there and then
that was literally three months before
my cancer diagnosis you know and that's
when
so i got diagnosed with cancer in june
of 2019
and in that moment we had just come back
from from puerto rico
and you know everything's great i'm
flying on the g5 everything was great
and now life got turned upside down and
and i had to fight the cancer
um over the last two years you know
physically
medically mentally spiritually
energetically but i didn't have to fight
it financially
is that that i was able to extract
myself out of the business
and have a financial machine to take
care of me without
having to shift our lifestyle without
having to sit back and say hey honey we
gotta sell things you know i mean so
sell her shoes which would have been
worse than a cancer
you know so it's like so
then right after that i watched the
pandemic hit
and i saw so many entrepreneurs that
were what i call treadmill entrepreneurs
and when that treadmill stopped so did
their money so did their lives that sort
of their passion so did their lies it
started they started struggling i go
man this is important that i took for
granted
how i built my business how i built my
financial life
and i you know and then that's when i
kind of said
you know my son tells me he goes dad he
says because i raised him as a single
full-time dad since he was six and he
said
you've always told me that financial
financial independence is a birthright
to go claim it
is this time you get that message in the
world and that's
that's really what the catalyst was how
do i go out there and get the message in
the world there's those that i work with
on one-on-one and my programs anything
but the reality is
that how do i actually give that belief
that
that the the tools the strategies and
some of that stuff to people
in the broader market and the best way
for me was the show
the best way for me was to show how are
you doing on the health side how's how's
the cancer
uh how are you feeling so uh three
surgeries four tumors
33 treatments and as of last two weeks
uh
two weeks ago i went in for my last
scope which was the one year milestone
completely clear completely clean done
so
we're not done in the sense that we
always have to watch over it but the
fact of the matter is i'm no longer
playing defense we're playing offense
we're preventing this bad boy from
coming back but i am clean healthy and
feeling great
makes me happy dude i think about you
maybe too much
if i'm honest like every for whatever
reason every time because i know you're
going on the runs
every time i go on a run which is three
to four times a week
you always pop into my head for for a
little moment while i'm doing my running
and and i think um i'm not gonna message
i'm not gonna text him again ask how
he's doing
it that feels like i'm a stalker but but
anyway i'm i'm super glad you're well
i appreciate uh you've always done that
and and you know it's funny because we
met we haven't known each other
too too long but it was there was just a
connection right from the get-go it
might have been because i convinced you
to start texting
that's true i think you might be the
first person i texted you
i was i would yeah mel abraham taught me
how to text
um okay so let's dive into some money
things so what i mean
the affluent entrepreneur it's a show
the pin comment is there
thank you to bo we pop that in uh go
check it out on itunes youtube the
youtube show is
is the same name or just mel abraham or
what it'll be under my mel abraham
channel as a playlist
so yeah unless you tell me i should be
doing it as a separate
no under under because you're not doing
other content on your channel right no
no yeah so just yeah mel abraham was
perfect uh and we can dive into youtube
stuff
later yeah also for those that are
android users
perfect so what are some of the biggest
mistakes
that entrepreneurs make or some of the
things that they need to know that they
don't think about when they're starting
their business around money
so i think one of the first things when
we start to think about uh
finances and business and money all
together is that
we separate the two we actually look at
the business and we're gonna i'm running
the business i'm running the business
and we step out of the business and now
we're gonna run our personal life our
financial life personally
well they're integrated they're one
they they they need to work in concert
with each other and that
if our business is ours is our primary
or my
my foundational wealth building tool
then how am i using it to actually build
wealth and the mistake
one of the big mistakes that they make
is that we're taking all our profits and
plowing it right back into the business
to grow the business now
at the beginning we got to do that for a
little while so we can get some traction
but at some point what we need to do is
start spinning off some of that profit
allocating slices of it so we're
building a financial machine
outside the business especially if
you're in personal brands because
most of our personal brands are not
celibate and there's nothing at the end
of the
day if we stop doing the work that we do
and so what we need to consider is how
do we use the business and integrate
our financial personal financial world
with our business world
in the sense that that one's funding the
other
what what i love about you is that you i
mean you work on some pretty
big complex giant
millions and millions and millions of
dollar deals but you can also break it
down to help the person who's
at the beginning just starting up and
and it's kind of rare because most
people like they specialize it's great
that you can you got all this
super wisdom here but you can bring it
down to the the everyday
you know joe um
what do you recommend for somebody who's
maybe in the earlier stages
where they don't have a lot of money
coming in do you say
okay once you hit a certain threshold or
no like from the beginning you have to
pay yourself first where where do you
stand on that
so i i stand on right from the beginning
here's here's what i believe
is that uh money issues most most people
do not have money issues
they have behavior issues that cause
money issues
and so what we need to do is start
building the right habits and behaviors
to shift our money issues and and
so the way we do that is in small
increments it's it's in small
doses and and so that's part of it the
other part of it is this
the the earlier the more we can front
load our investing
the earlier we start building wealth the
more the heavy lifting is done by time
if it because what happens is that when
we build wealth it stays flat for a
little while you're putting
fifty dollars in a week and you don't
see it
you don't see it growing then all of a
sudden it starts to ramp up because it
starts to get money momentum as i call
it
and when that money momentum hits listen
50 bucks a week
turns into 350 000 over a couple decades
and you know now if you put it to 200
bucks a week and you're putting
you know 800 a month away now the sudden
you've got 1.2 million dollars
but the problem is that we often wait to
start developing the muscle and all of a
sudden we never
develop the muscle and the habits so i
start them right from the get-go
the other thing that i think we need to
think about is what i call the
the wealth priority pathway most people
live their life this way
they they earn income and then they
spend it
they look at what's left and then
they'll use that to invest
the problem is what you're investing for
is your future
which means that what you're using for
your future is just the scraps
because we didn't make it a priority
when you look at the
the wealthy the truly truly wealthy what
they do is they earn income
they make well uh wealth building and
investing a priority so they invest
first
they look at what's left and say this is
for my lifestyle
and and they start to create the
lifestyle based on that and if they
don't like it
then it's time to figure out how we can
earn more ramp it up scale it up
optimize
profits so we have more for the
lifestyle but we don't forsake our
future
in the process if somebody's at the
beginning
to get tactical what how much am i
saving or what kind of percentage of
revenue or however we're calculating it
and then where am i putting it if i'm
not a sophisticated
investor so here's a couple a couple
things first things first
is what i want people to do is get a
vision for their their life what what is
their financial vision because
until we have a target we just start
throwing things we don't even know when
we
we've hit the finish line and too often
we're looking at how do i replace my
income well let's figure out
let's take a quick look at the at our
lifestyle figure out what that lifestyle
should look like
and now let's put a price tag on it so
now we have a target
and once we have the target what i try
to try to get my clients to do is
at some point depending on age at some
point i actually want them putting 20 to
25 percent of their income away now
some people say i can't i'm barely
paying my bills now
and i go all right so if you're just
starting out and you don't have
that cushion in your cash flow then
here's a couple things i want you to do
i want you to start looking at starting
at five percent
just start at five percent trust me if
you start to look at it and you say
i'm making 50 000 a year i'll shoot i'm
gonna do math on the fly here
at 50 000 a year that's that's 200 bucks
a month it's
50 a week okay that i'm putting away
50 a week is basically 10 bucks every
working day
and so if we went through your your
bills if we went through your credit
card statements if we went through
um your your bank statements i bet that
we could find
some some leaks that you could take and
find 10 bucks a day
to put away and and build that up and
you know i've heard so many people say
and this is our dear friend you know
david bach talks about the latte factor
and i've heard people you know ridicule
it and they go
now wait a second if the objective is to
build behavior to build habits
we start with a latte factor but that
grows
into something that that is amazing
because you have built the muscle the
habits and the
and the things that most people that
build wealth do
we can't expect to build wealth if we're
not doing the same things that they do
and so so i would start out with five
percent
and then every quarter every quarter
i would look at how do you grow it how
do you increase it by one percentage
point one and a half percentage points
until you get yourself to a point
that you're up at twenty percent of your
income
and it just it's going to take time you
might be working in a job
and you're not an entrepreneur you
totally get it and if that's the case
you get a raise let's say they give you
a cost of living raising they give you
three percent
i get it take one and a half percent of
that raise
and move it into your your your your
future
and then live off of that additional one
half percent you still get a little bit
of a raise
but you're also contributing that raise
until you get to that
that that percentage point that makes
sense and then
and then you can work from there now
where do you put it initially
initially if you don't have a retirement
account
and depending on what country you're in
you know whether it's ira
uh roth or some some plans in canada in
the uk
then i would find at the beginning a
high yield cash account
and just transfer it i want it out of
sight out of mind
i want it automatic so if i know that
i'm going to
get a salary check that's the same every
month
and i'm going to say i want five percent
to go to this account
every month and you set it up with your
bank it's automatic it's out of sight
out of mind here's
here's what i'm trying to do i want to
take
the friction away from all of your
investing
and i want to put the friction in for
all of your spending
i want to make it harder for you to
spend and easier for you to invest
and too often it's the other way around
oh i got to write a check i got to go to
the brokerage account i got to do this
and then we never do it because i
haven't got around to it because
there's too much friction to get you
there and so we
want to make it automatic and so those
are the first few things that i would do
now high yield cash account
they don't have they don't yield a ton
but they yield more than a savings
account
um in today's inter low interest rate
environment
but there's three characteristics of a
high yield cash account i think you want
to look at one
is that it is 100 fully liquid
okay so i can get access to the money
anytime
because once we accumulate enough in
there then we'll probably put it into
some sort of investments
okay but at the beginning we only have
50 bucks or
or a hundred dollars at a time going in
there we might want to accumulate it
into a lump sum
of a couple thousand and then move it in
the second characteristic of a high
yield cash account is that it is insured
this is your this is your future this is
your liquid funds
i want to make sure it's insured most of
most of the the banks especially in the
us
um and in canada they have certain
levels of insurance 250 000
or so or so so you make sure it's
insured we want to keep it safe
and the third aspect of it is that it's
completely free of any fees
they're not going to charge you anything
to have the account and so
when we do that money's coming in 5
is moving off it's accumulating in a
high-yield cash account
at some point we then look at at that
and say hey i think i'm going to move it
into some index funds or an etf or some
other investment
from there but i want it off your
spending off your list
so now it is it is moving out of sight
out of mind so you have the ability to
then
invest it the entrepreneurs who maybe
are
are minimizing the income that they have
because they don't want to pay a lot of
taxes
do you ever move to model of instead of
percentage
of income percentage of revenue for the
business
so i actually um
i actually do percentage of revenue when
we start to grow
at that level and so one of the things
and then it just depends on how we do it
um look um
this is something that we did in in the
in the past years because income levels
were growing and this and that
i put a specific type of retirement plan
into my business into my company called
a defined benefit plan that allows me to
put a ton
more away that i can invest
get a tax deduction and still have
control of the money
so what we need to do is as you start to
grow
is we need to look for the avenues that
fit your circumstances and
and when i say circumstances it's your
revenues how how
big of a company is what kind of cash
flow the regularity of the cash flow
your age because uh i don't know how
i'm well i'm not supposed to ask a lady
her age but i can ask you how old are
you
i turned 41 in on may 20th so however
many days that is
coming dude man it's eight days away a
week away it's coming i know
wow i'll be 60 this year are you kidding
me you're
60 september 2nd i yeah i know actually
holy cow dude you do not you look you're
looking great
for 60. that's crazy yeah thank you
thank you
um so here's the thing i got
almost 20 years on you the investments
that you would go in
would be very different than the
investments that i'm going
you know because you have this longer
runway now hopefully i have a long
runway too
but but you're 20 years behind me you're
19 years behind me type of a thing
so we can take a little more risks with
you
that we might not take with me and so
circumstances are dictated by age and
stage
but the investing principles
work no matter what you know i look at
my son who's um
he's 31 his wife is 27.
uh they're expecting their first child
so i'm gonna be a granddad for the first
time
look out world uh i'm in trouble it's
gonna be a granddaughter so i
have no idea how i would ever say no to
that little princess you're going to
spoil her crate
you're going to swear like crazy it's
going to be crazy
here they are 31-27 now like i said i
raised him since he was uh
um six so he's been he's been
brainwashed into all of this thinking
and at this age already they have three
homes they have a multi-million dollar
net worth
they literally know i talk about
the idea of being an affluent
entrepreneur is to live a rich life and
not just a wealthy life and so
after they found out that they're having
a daughter they looked at my wife and i
said hey can you watch our dog
and i go sure we love watching we love
your dog yeah yeah
how long he said for a month i go
a month what are you talking about a
month i go he says
well we know when the when the baby's
born we're not going to get as much time
to travel
so we just rented an airbnb in maui and
we're going there for a month
and it's because they set their business
and their life
up right that allowed them the
liberation the freedom
to do something like that and that's
what i think we're entitled to
it and there's nothing wrong with with
looking towards that and trying to make
that happen
i love it dude uh somebody's asking how
can i get in contact with mel he shared
amazing advice and
love the way he explains things well the
affluent entrepreneur let's go check
that show out for sure
and and then like where do people
connect with you instagram
email your website courses what what so
i've got
uh so uh instagram for sure uh my
website
is melabraham.com and we have i do have
programs called the affluent the
affluent uh affluence blueprint which
walks through some of the principles and
the processes and
and then the tools and all that stuff um
and
and then the show i'm gonna be taking so
the show is gonna be a combination this
is partly you this is you're doing it
um so it's going to be me me teaching
um me teaching and then also me bringing
guests on
uh like this so evan will bring uh bring
you on and we'll have conversations
but also taking questions and doing
live mentoring and live coaching on
on air with with folks just like just
like you do and so
so it is a place that i want people to
connect it's a place where we can have
real conversations about money that are
safe
i mean too often we demonize money too
often we we say it's taboo don't talk
about it but
fact of the matter is that there's no
problem in the world that ever gets
solved if we don't have conversations
around it
so let's have real conversations and not
make it bad
you look at um you look at what we can
do
when we have the financial flexibility
to do things i mean another dear friend
of ours allison
allison j prince um so
i was i was working there she called me
up uh
she called me up about a year ago and
said she goes you're the only one i can
talk to
about this and so what's up she says i
hit all my numbers
and i said well that's freaking great
you hit all your numbers
i said but why don't you sound excited
and she said
what do i do now like what do you mean
she goes do i just
increase the numbers i go ah so one of
the core principles that i talk about is
that we need to know our why before our
how and how much
and i said let's talk about your why
well her why
is to give women the possibility of
independence in their lives
and so we restructured her business in a
way that every time she made a sale
she she make a micro loan to a woman in
the third third world country
and this last last week we her and i did
an interview on a live and she says do
you know after we
reworked this do you know how many
microphones we've given out in just a
year's time
i said and i'm thinking it's like 500 i
don't know you know that seems like a
big number to me
she goes over 7 000.
that's awesome oh my god seven thousand
seven thousand families
lives have changed because we had the
the funding and we
changed it to work it in a certain range
because and you know what's even more
beautiful
she goes i'm not doing it in my name i'm
doing it in all of my customers names
and they get the credit and i go that's
why we shouldn't be talking about money
because we have the ability
i don't think i truly believe that when
we stand shoulder shoulder as a humanity
we can solve anything and that's what i
want to do
guys mel is one of the smartest guys i
know around money and he's also got a
giant heart
and uh i definitely think you should go
check out the affluent entrepreneur
mel super appreciate the time man i'm so
glad that you're doing this
and i mean this is one small thing we
can do together but if i can be of any
value to you and building this up
i'm in thank you but thank you buddy i i
look forward to it
i appreciate you bringing me on saying
hi it's just good to see your smiling
face
i love it dude check it out guys
affluent entrepreneur appreciate you mel
i'll talk to you soon
thanks buddy if you want to see the
one-on-one i did with tony robbins check
it out
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there the quality of
your life has nothing to do with how
much money you have on any beautiful
children you have how many people love
you
the quality of your life is where you
live emotionally